Hey everyone.  Welcome to Snacks, Inc.
Where snack lovers get their favorite combos.
We've got chips, pretzels, soda, and a whole lot of snacking strategy going on.
But behind the crunch and fizz is a surprisingly tricky pricing puzzle.
Let's dig in.
Snack Sink sells three big hits.
Crunchy chips, classic pretzels and fizzy pop.
Here's where it gets interesting.
Chips and pretzels substitutes.
You're not going to eat both in one sitting.
Chips and soda compliments a salty snack and a fizzy drink.
Total snack time.  Power cup.
Here is the issue.
Pretzels go on sale and boom.
Chip sales drop, customers switch over and snack sync loses profits.
That's called cannibalization.
When one product steals sales from its sibling, you think you're winning customers, but really you're just reshuffling them and may be making less money doing it.
So what's the move?
Think of these products as a bundle of substitutes.
Don't just price them randomly.
Raise the price on both.
But here's the twist.
Raise it more on the product, lower margins and more price sensitive buyers.
In this case, that's the chips.
This nudges folks towards the higher margin pretzels and softens the overlap.
Still worried about cannibalization?
Let's get clever with marketing pitch.
Pretzels as a light, wholesome snack.
Perfect for an afternoon desk much.
Make chips the weekend party.
Treat different vibes, different occasions.
Less direct competition.
Now they're not fighting for the same moment.
Now let's talk combos.
Chips and fizzy pop.
These two go together like movie night and pajamas.
When you own complementary products, the key move is to lower prices a little on both.  Why?
Because a small price cut can boost demand for both items together.
More chips, more pop, more total revenue.
Even better, make it official.
Launch a movie night combo with a discounted bundle price.
By treating chips and soda as a single offering, Snack Sync can optimize the price for the whole experience, not just the parts.
Think like a customer.
Two for one feels way better than separate buys.
At the end of the day, it's all about understanding how your products relate.  Substitutes.
Manage them carefully.
Compliments, bundle them smartly.
Snack sync does both and their profits are popping.
Now that's tasty pricing.